you get summoned by the Wild and
wonderful QT we go over his house
because the last script got leaked so he
wasn't having any of that sit down at
his table he usually makes you a tea and
he'll tell you about the story for about
an hour you may not know this he's a bit
verbal and then you read the script
alone he'll come and check on you about
halfway and it was pretty crisp pretty
clean script one script and read it and
uh was um quite taken with it I don't
know several weeks later and that same
script was there but it was all
dog-eared and stained you know that
we've all kind of everyone's come in
well it's interesting because he wants
to have this one-on-one immediate
reaction and he's constantly checking on
you to see if you're laughing at the
right spot flip Booth is uh was the name
of the the stunt man it's really drawn
to him I love what Quentin had written
it was a guy who was pretty at peace
with his place in life looked for the
best in people but was not surprised to
get the worst in people I I could relate
to that